what is up everyone
we are live and in a q screen
so i am david ahmadi i will be your host
today i'm excited to bring you guys here
on reset day witch queen day it is the
day for destiny fans everywhere and i am
joined by two of gamespot's destiny
resident experts john luke so if you say
hello
hello hi i've already been in the queue
and i'm back i'm in the game right now
actually oh man waiting for you david
yeah
and uh phil
say what's up hey
i'm also in the game i'm very excited to
be here yeah destiny decided to give our
lore expert and our hunter expert the uh
the go-ahead and they decided to give me
uh the vanity curse because i've been
spending some time trying to fix my
camera which is not live so you guys are
just gonna have to deal with my pretty
voice
uh but we are good to go and man i am i
am stoked i am super excited oh hey
looks like the chris has lifted i think
it's putting me in right now nice oh
sick
excellent so you're gonna get a cut
scene and then um
after that invite us to your party okay
because me and phil are ready to go um
yeah we're set beautiful beautiful
you gotta yeah you're gonna have to look
at all the void stuff too by the way oh
absolutely yeah you can you can do that
when you first hop in yeah
all right let's see this cutscene let's
see what we gotta got
i'll be quiet for the cutscene
so phil's gonna be on his titan john
luke you're on the hunt here so i will
be picking my warlock
in times of crisis
people look to their leaders for answers
but ever since the planets were ripped
from our sky
it seems all i can offer are more
questions
and now
with mars return
i hardly know where to start
oh that's some sick armor
where is she
our theory was correct the relic is off
the pyramids there's no doubt
word is
i need more time
okay
sick
ah very nice very nice
oh damn
whoa all right dude whoa whoa whoa what
is this okay we have uh it's asking you
if i want legend or classic yeah wow all
right that's the first second legend
dude well i'm here we go i'm picking
classic for the stream obviously i'm
just kidding um
so
yeah let me let me read this real quick
and show it so yeah you got two
different ones and
oh nice okay so it says
the gear bundle that they're going to
give us the 1520 so that's just blue
right but it's basically like infusion
fodder i guess
yes exactly so we can like take whatever
we actually want and just infuse it up
that's very nice
and they gave us like eight upgrade
modules yeah what's up
the chat was saying to crank up the
volume so um uh of the of the game
yeah i think for the cut scenes well
maybe okay you might need to ride that
during cut scenes versus uh versus
gameplay uh versus game play i got you
okay i mean you're all gonna want to be
quiet and just pay attention to that
stuff right right okay great great show
also don't forget to go grab your your
new exotic off the season pass i was
literally about to say that
sounds good sounds good
um so don't launch yet invite us to your
party after you grab your uh okay
we'll do let me let me just
uh
change that
okay cool
uh let me add you guys
weapon wasn't not letting me do i have
to like back out of this menu first
probably okay oh yeah if you hit back
yeah if you back out um all right no
worries
or we could i could try i could try
joining also um
i've already acquired my first aspect oh
i like the new map oh [ __ ] okay
it's like nice like sickly green on the
left in the in a a reef mara soft purple
on the right it's very cool
also is it just me or is it like easier
to read the vanguard like the text has
changed yeah the text is a little
different yeah
goodbye argumentation
uh
okay i'm gonna try and uh just join you
okay yeah do that sorry i'm on the the
void 3.0 page right now it's going to
take a minute to page through all that
garbage yeah well it's more so because
like the tooltips like blasting at me
right now it's like you want this
yes it's kind of frustrating honestly
they will it's hard to get them to go
away
yeah
but i do
so they just give you the aspects you
don't have to do like a long ass quest
or anything you know this is something
they said in the [ __ ] but they're not
gonna make us if you're new you gotta go
earn it all but if you're not new then
congratulations
yeah you get everything
except for the few that they locked off
yeah
oh i see i see okay okay these are for
the raid nice
all right these are damn these are sick
tooltip go away i know how to [ __ ]
i know how to equip fragments man just
get out of here yeah yeah
there we go okay what do i have to press
to make it disappear like okay escape a
bunch of times i found yes
if you back out it'll just kind of
it'll just stop it'll
it'll set it forward you got to like go
back and forth a couple times yeah
that's that's what i was doing i'm just
spamming this video right now okay
all right let me go back to you
oh that's so funny
uh oh yeah that's the new melee pocket
singularity okay cool child of the old
gods chaos accelerant i'll just uh
i'll just add the ones that give me
some stat bonuses for now
uh all right
and you guys are in yeah
yeah yeah we're in your party beautiful
okay start her up
let's go yeah let's do it
just
quickly all right a lot of a lot of void
happening yeah yeah oh yeah
where is
there we go
all right
oh sorry you said season pass and you
gotta get my exotic
grand over tour there we go
savathun's throne world the arrival and
then uh
so it just says launch but is it going
to automatically throw us at the legends
level or is there like a way to take it
specifically
i assume that we because we all picked
it
uh i assume we'll be good but yeah i
guess i don't 100 now i have no idea uh
we'll we'll find out i mean
although hmm didn't give you another
chance to pick it no it won't
between every match or every mission so
like yeah here john legend go ahead and
let me make you leader because i i'm not
seeing the legendary option anymore so
i'm just gonna i don't i don't i don't
see it on mine either so it's not gonna
all
change
well
it should give us a try for something to
let us know if we
cleared it on legend if not we'll do it
again
we'll do it live
or we could play it again and
bump the volume if you want people to
hear it
sure bumping the volume now
where is she
your theory was correct the relic is of
the pyramids there's no doubt
word is out about mars
i need more time
the cabal are mobilizing
we need to
secure the camp
wait
it seems they have another target what
are they aiming at
[Music]
savathun
choice
yes we got our legend choice uh chat let
us know if you were able to hear any of
that audio cutscene because i definitely
crank the volume up and i'm seeing the
the game's music go up on the um
the audio mixer
supposedly it's better
okay all right
you guys good
uh yes
let's do this thing
phil do you have an eye on the the chat
yes okay cool yeah i have it on chat too
oh perfect people are saying it's better
now yeah oh god it might have been a
delay then while i was yeah it might
have been because like
people were saying it or
maybe before
all right
oh my god you want to hear about some
lore [ __ ] subclass 3.0 tool tip
popping up again i don't want to inspect
my goddamn subclass man
yeah dude i get it
get this menu out of here okay
oh let's
into the go age
mars has returned with temporal
instability
we believe the reappearance of mars
drove her out of hiding and our intel
says
and this crop field looks doper than the
one in battlefield
[Laughter]
autumn
not to knock battlefield that was a mean
joke but i thought i mean i don't know
this place looks sick
yeah i like this whole
what does that look like
a little bit a little bit of titanfall 2
kind of stuff yeah
uh we want to we want to [ __ ] up these
no that's the cradle man that's the
place the traveler touched on mars
oh really that over there yeah
no
all right all right already i'm yep this
is definitely on legendary
oh yeah oh there are there's three of us
okay elsa's giving me tool tips about
how energy weapons work and i'm like
game
yeah so we're at what we're at 1350 so
the light level for this is 1360 so it's
10 above yes or 10 under okay so it
can't be it's not too bad i might have
to change this gun though i picked a lot
of random stuff because i never played
titan
might also be good to get those arbolets
out i'm thinking
oh that's a good call yeah i have a i
have something for void but yeah for the
other one
for this
i'm gonna do it oh what is
oh this is how the shoe gun works yeah
is it is it shooting it like the
colossus do you know how they blasted
it's a slug it's a slug machine gun
until you like charge it up and then it
can do missiles
oh that's crazy oh he dropped a thing
heavy objects will slow you down press
yep left to use
on the one hand i'm like happy that
they're fully aware that a lot of new
people are gonna be in here and have no
idea what the hell is going on so but
like can they like differentiate between
who's been here like who's got 1700
hours of the game and who doesn't like
come on man
video game please yeah hold on i am
switching i'm going to switch over to
our list because yeah
um was there an option for tooltips
maybe in the settings real quick no i
don't think that that has ever been a
thing oh there's display hints so i'm
just going to turn that off oh okay well
oh that's where loaded sequences but
still yeah
yeah you'll be my guide phil you'll be
my guide
i'll leave them on just in case it tells
us anything we actually do need to yeah
okay we brought a really big gun
this will solve the problem
yeah that's how you defeat a god with a
gun
extremely large
i gotta like learn
how this class works yeah i gotta
remember i'm a titan
gotta punch stuff
nice oh yeah everybody explodes because
my void
stuff oh it's nice nice
oh i ate that
seems too reckless
david you are alone over there and we
are
doing a hacking thing over here
nice
oh this ion is just going for it
oh hey i got a little void buddy
hell yeah yeah your little void soul
yeah
okay
okay thank you
[Laughter]
okay
if you're saying the um
they can just hear a lot of like
keyboard stuff and and
okay mike's too high
let's start with opening the fuel lines
okay so let me swap some stuff here
don't worry we'll keep shooting
all of these dudes
i'd love to spend an entire afternoon
checking audio and then it just were
yeah people are just saying they really
can't hear the game audio for whatever
reason
but it like exists right like it's not
like just
devoid of game audio
i don't know
well because if they were saying like oh
it got if they're saying like oh it got
better
then i assume that means that they were
able to hear at least some of it
i'm just gonna
crank this up and discord
i'm just gonna go off the the meter
level so let's came out of here
[Music]
oh my god
oh yeah there's a pressure up there
now
oh it's huge
i'm just gonna have to like account the
chat delay and like try to remember what
i changed it to and then what they say
in like two minutes
one down button one more time
wrench
thanks
this guy's got it out for us
uh
[Music]
oh that's a big wrench
that has a big that's a cabal wrench
right there
we're getting paid for this
so you don't know
yeah sorry guys i forgot my time card
oh crap it's not here come here comes
more pots
come on
generators
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
i just dropped it in already
oh
oh that sounds still alive
so the new void ability it's like a
putting a titan detonator in
that's a warlock and they just like
hover with it
[Music]
oh okay if i were a god of cunning i
wouldn't show up with a giant ship
it's like saying
here i am come kill me
oh we got we got funny guys
waving a red flag
i think it's in the chat chris was
saying that the rally banners don't seem
to take from your
the campaign banners don't take from
your rally banners oh that's nice
extremely nice yeah that would be really
very nice
we need two override codes to get the
lift moving don't do the cabal engineers
carry them
oh we're in the darkness zone now yeah
this is where the first of the major
encounters
does that happen for uh regular campaign
oh liftover right
oh
um
oh here it is
oh i can't get you yeah
oh
okay so okay gotcha
so we each only have one token okay hang
on one second we'll like
fix this now you're fine
okay now it's ward
okay so yeah so we usually have one
token and yeah if you don't revive the
time
oh yeah don't dismantle your blues i
almost just by automatically almost
dismantled loose but they're actually
dropping higher now
we need two override codes to get the
lift
only cabal engineers carry them
together
first
uh
i should be illegals
all right
over here
wall going up
well
he like showed us back to you and then
jumped at you backwards
that's one way to do it
get me to that console i'll activate the
lift
more dudes over here
we just have to adjust the trajectory
now
oh we're gonna use some blue guns i
guess yeah let's go
i actually didn't get any guns
oh congratulations
uh yeah
i don't want to like dump all my
infusion stuff on
oh i'm doing it right now as we speak
i do not give a [ __ ]
we'll see we'll see how good how bad it
gets
yeah over time
okay
cool
when i was searching for the canon
schematics i saw marching letters from
titles
i'm not sure how she'll feel about us
interfering
do you just die if you stay on the
wasn't jeep attention
[Laughter]
all right the cannon is aligning time to
reload guardian
we're going to shoot the gunners
but i'll stand by to revive
yeah i guess we killed all of them that
we're gonna blow it up you know so we're
just gonna have to do it
yeah
we're like you're doing the right thing
but we want to do it
encounter with queen mara that she's
getting clumsy
i'm hoping for the latter but
i wouldn't bet on it
yeah this is season 16.
woah
[Music]
did you hit that ship
no i think i hit you
oh i get i get to ride the cannon again
nice nice nice
i i appreciate this repurposing of uh
that one raid
yeah back at the leviathan
yeah david and i landed there
your floppy body came
tumbling past us
we made it under the ship and we're
seeing traces of void light seems like
maybe another guardian got up here first
that's impossible
perhaps we've acted too hastily
there are too many unknowns
salvathoon is the god of coming
to wait for a moment when her intentions
are clear
we would wait forever not forever just
until we can provide backup
guardian iris and i are pinned down
if you turn back now it'll give us more
time to plan
i don't think sabathune will give us
free time agora this might be our only
shot
don't worry we'll handle it be careful
creepy uh there's a door down here
um
void light that's a callback to the
sabbath song strike man
oh sure
that's not that's not some guardian
ahead of us that
that's they captured some void light
from turning people into crystals
dude i've like missed this aesthetic
i love it so cool
that knight have an overshield
he did
watch out for those like moth things do
you remember that you see that drop just
now yeah it was glowing with light
not corrupted light guardian
but light like ours
so the losing guys when you pop their
shields uh it generates like a little
light moth
and the moth can fly to other enemies
and power them up with the shield so you
have to shoot them off
and the mouth will explode if you get
too close to the moth the moth will
charge you like a thrall and try to blow
you up
okay
okay this is
oh
shot it
so multiple waves
marvelous next
so
so
oh the trippy dropped
okay the tribute can disappear like
modes
oh that was it
this just isn't adding up we need to
find sabathun
oh upgrades don't cost anything but
upgrade modules now too that's sick okay
so if they're just gonna keep throwing
upgrades at us i'm just gonna keep
upgrading
yeah that's a good point actually i
don't know i want to mess with the the
blues here seems chill
i mean i banked a ton anyway
yeah
yes i think all of these are just going
right to my
uh postmaster anyway
yeah maybe you're right
yeah for the time being i'm gonna kick
my light up
um while you guys are in the menu i'm
gonna run to the bathroom real quick
okay
upgrading
okay
upgrades there
did we get vanguard rep for um
story
that's a good question
um
all right
bring this browser over to this other
side
the most exciting part of any live
stream
spooky
was that from like a e3 uh
that was uh yeah the lady from yeah the
ghost writer
that was just not on that game anymore
though that was still a lovely
presentation
these guys
they're like hey you picked legendary
not us pal
i should put a special finisher on i
think
did you just get one did you get a
number okay i just did it
i'm picking up unusual energy from that
statue
these are the ones that are like
supposed to point right if you like have
like a true sight or something
i think this is the statue you're
talking about yeah oh maybe up there
never mind
yeah deep sight
oh deep side is what it's called okay
yeah oh crap
yo that what's that that thing hurt that
would be the mop nothing took out like
the shields entirely oh my god
there's another one
yeah those moths will attack if you
don't shoot them guardian yeah thanks
[Laughter]
in case you didn't notice
oh damn it
titan
that was that was tight
that's what it probably is default to me
dude the chandeliers that we pass by
remind me of like the spiders and um i
think it's like what nightmare offenses
or something in bloodborne yeah yeah
yeah this has a whole big bloodborne
energy
i've never seen anything like it
oh yeah oh yeah what is this oh it's
glee time that's what it is but also
what is this thing it's just a pair of
legs like pyramid technology
what's it doing on sabbath ship
that's right you're right we should
bring it back to aikora
this is new pyramid stuff we've never
seen
oh it's got like spiky legs yeah
this is what's under that weirdo
nice
sweet
oh
nice
tank in those nova bombs
oh
[Music]
and more steps
i'm
can be problematic
yeah this is
gargoyles up ahead
[Music]
all right well they just keep jumping
right off
i
exploded him off
he looked like
i love the hive aesthetic it's so good
yeah
there are reports of sabathoom trying to
capture void light from dead guardians
maybe this is related
maybe she's been studying the void all
this time
could that be how she did this
reports dude we were there
i hate it when ghost acts like he
doesn't know stuff because
all that stuff
like bro
what is this
oh
my god
that's like an eyeball yeah
it's like moving around dude it's like
some sauron's boy die like yup
oh this is
another wild fun statue
what is this supposed to be just like a
hive night or like zebra or something
yeah i don't know exactly
some dark blades
oh wow
that was sabbath hurry
she just went through that portal
yeah dude this is crazy
wow
this is incredible
oh my god
we didn't even have a rally
that's a one hit ko dude oh my god
i mean it's a super right so
makes sense
oh no that's impossible
is that a ghost damn right it is
get me closer guardian i have to
[Music]
see it
okay that was really cool
yo nice bubble dude
there's no other way
get out of here
push it
like me
you see that right
i
i can't believe this
what have i done
what has she done to you
all right now we get the real deal
oh no no it uses it for you as soon as
you plant it yeah
oh we're getting true okay so we have to
go back to the plate every time we get a
tribute or whatever
um
oh
yeah phil you're gonna have to grab me
and i promise i won't blow myself up
with that with the galley
trying to
dive in a weird spot
on the uh on the spike
i think we're done anyway
oh yeah these are some huge upgrade
jumps like plus 20.
i'm really happy that they give you
upgrade modules the whole time yeah
it's very although it's just it's just
two so you're gonna
you have to be able to choose you can't
go nuts but it's definitely nice to just
be able to
keep your gear like you keep the stuff
that you're obviously using right
i think this is a new gun optimum pr six
pulse rifle
that already has a kill tracker very
nice
yeah oh yeah
let's go let's do it
oh that was it yeah yeah yeah nice nice
oh here we are is this place
this doesn't look like a hive throne
world
so this is the stuff i got to see in the
preview oh yeah
basically you know two thirds of this
mission and then some free roam dude
just call this [ __ ] destiny 2 dark
souls like this is incredible yeah it's
excellent i'm really into it
this is so sick
what's this over here
oh just some cool lighting just uh you
know
sam dude's got the interior decorating
down
yeah yeah
she's definitely she definitely planned
out you know her build with the
contractor like a builder architect the
whole
the whole thing dude look at these
hedges immaculately trimmed
okay
sorry
that was really funny
that night like doubled over while being
launched in the air by suppression was
kind of hurtful
it's her
how did you do it
how did you find the strength to destroy
something so like yourself
like that sparta kick man that's gotta
hurt you're right
i think he's brutal
oh wow
those wings man
yeah it's gross honestly
[Music]
oh we can damage all right
war
oh
no that was scary
yeah
i just saw i just saw my own nova bomb
just come right back at me like
that was messed up
oh boy
can't get to our chest
it did seem too easy
[Laughter]
right
damn i gotta like take a breathe uh
breath i was like
i was it was intense man for one mission
that was cool
and like a normal destiny campaign that
would be like three or four different
missions you know what i mean yeah
yeah what i ended with the first major
encounter basically
exactly yeah like each major encounter
would have been its own uh would have
been its own mission you're absolutely
right
someone in chat saw uh
sabotaging throw that nova bomb back at
me and just called it an uno reverse
card
[Laughter]
it was a long load
servers
somebody grab a fire extinguisher for
the server please
[Laughter]
dude yeah you look you look at the
roster right now everyone's on this this
is the best part of the day it's just
like look at this
two and a half pages worth of people
just all online having a blast
i love it
love it love it love it
i suppose i'll check in with work for
the moment
gal is from poland greetings what time
is it in poland right now they got to be
like what maybe
10 hours ahead 11 hours ahead
and i haven't even had a chance to fully
look at the chat legendary campaign's
been so intense
take my eyes off the screen for one
second and i'm probably dead
i was definitely getting run over by
those acolytes i need to boost my
resistance pretty badly
yeah as you know saying the dlc uh
hopefully it's not done in just like
five missions but i think they said like
10 or something
uh right in the preview we got a sense
of how long it was supposed to be and we
were supposed to not say so okay
we'll find out we'll find out
we're you know we're out of embargo at
this point however
if you guys don't want to be spoiled on
it
let's just say it's it's pretty long
oh hell yeah yeah that's that's a good
way to put it yeah yeah awesome it's
it's longer they the way bungie put it
it's longer than
um
probably anything they've done in a
while i think is how they they they were
unwilling to say it was the longest ever
but it might be the longest ever given
how long that mission was right i don't
know man i think we're going to be i
think we're going to be kicking at this
thing
i got booted yeah yeah i think i think
that might be happening to me too um i'm
thinking we
are at least looking at d2 vanilla
campaign length right out there right
right
it's not only that there are a lot of
missions which there are but they're
very long as you saw so um
it's um
beefy go ahead and join me and then
we'll keep going okay
uh yeah i got kicked at orbit because
you were dropped so
all right that's david
okey-dokey
as he knows the spoiler i'm watching a
live stream it's an occasion
[Laughter]
you know what i i i respect your
your output on that because a lot of
people don't feel that way
they get real
i can tell you this right now when we
jump into the next mission
spoilers for the story for sure um
i mean obviously we're playing through
the story but
definitely a big one is coming because i
saw it in the preview and again we
weren't supposed to talk about it and so
you know enjoy it's time to bounce if
you want it if you don't want to know
about
certain things
oh i see what you're saying okay like
witch queen spoilers yeah
oh yeah i mean like spoilers for the
campaign story
a significant twist is about to come so
gotcha gotcha but but this is like
specifically for this dlc you didn't
mean spoilers for like past dlcs or
something like that right like a
catch-up of in case of
because like if they're if they're if
they're new players that like they've
never seen beyond light or something no
i don't think it will be well i mean you
know this all kind of like just builds
off of this is specifically about what
we're about to see in the throne
okay cool
so
oh okay
yeah here we go so patrol patrol space
social space what is this yeah it's a
it's like a helm
ask
okay
and oh damn
a lot of
how much
evidence board
yeah there's a seasonal challenge for
this week to connect three
strings or something something so
let's see let's see if we can do it is
there a vault oh thank god okay i'm
gonna dump a bunch of stuff in here
i'm not gonna take with me
[Music]
[Music]
yeah it's gonna be junk loot time
because of the leveling we're gonna be
dealing with a lot of it right that's
okay it seems like we're making good
progress sorry i was referring i was
talking to the chat but uh
it seems like we're gonna we're gonna
level up pretty quick so yeah that's the
that's a good thing with it for too long
yeah all right let's see what this is
all about seven inch board just want to
keep my thing i can't do anything here
okay
i'm just dropping stuff off because
we're gonna be getting a lot of
gear okay yeah yeah make some space
in theory all we need to do to solve
this is eliminate the impossible
i'll swirl this warlock's looking npc
he's just talking in theory all we gotta
do is eliminate the impossible all right
you nerd
[ __ ] warlock students swear
all right let's see if icor is probably
gonna have dialogue so i'm gonna listen
to it nightbearing
complete with their own ghosts
i should have seen this coming
but how
we're in a new paradigm now guardian
where the boundaries between are
becoming increasingly blurred especially
between what's right and what's wrong
if i had been in your place
to be honest i don't know what i would
have done
but there's no use dwelling on that
let's assess what we do know
i see you picked up a clue along the way
one that might explain why savathun
decided to return alongside mars
according to your ghost telemetry that
fragment is giving off the same
vibrations as the pyramid tech relic
that just so happened to return with
mars
go take a look
i'll explain more when you report back
enclave is this that's where we are okay
uh the relic is the oh
the thing
for
crafting oh sorry did i pull you guys
with me yeah
sorry my bad
i didn't realize i would do that
i mean did you just in uh investigate
the relic or whatever it was yeah yeah
okay cool google so at least we're all
on the whatever we were doing
yeah my bad
slow load again though
oh okay here we go cutscenes
sick
nice
very nice
the glade looks ridiculous i'm very
excited
i'm stoked about the idea of shooting
many bubble shields out
right
oh yeah okay this whole area looks
shape here we go
enigma yes thank you
she's coming off
uh i think we want the shield
so i can only pick one really
yeah the intrinsic right the adaptive
blade
right and then oh okay and then
obviously yeah level it up to unlock all
this other garbage gotcha okay so
there's range there's shield duration
alloy mag or extended maps
oh
all right
here we go
i tried to make a defensive one
oh i made more of a ranged one yeah
[Music]
i love that ui
yeah it's cool
it's just [ __ ] sick
okay there's a little memento slot here
and the date that i shaved it 222 2022
max
ray's shield and then kinetic melee
combo
sick let me put the excellent right now
oh wait it also came in at a huge high
level it's under your special slot
oh it's a special weapon okay i thought
it was a heavy for some reason
momentous slot
moments by completing high difficulty
activities
yeah like you'll get one for doing
seasonal stuff for the for gambit and
for the other activities
all right i gotta give this a cool color
uh yeah that's that's a good call
give it a nice one
spiff it up yeah
i'm so partial to like black and blue
and like white i gave it a white i gave
it a white and purple yeah
okay so
all right
let's roll
let's do it there's something over here
[Music]
relic conduit
um oh it's a mission
use weapons with deep sight resonance in
order to gather resonant materials from
them is until you improve your shape
weapon or shape new ones
all this sounds like it'd be great for a
explainer video
uh-huh
maybe later
okay we gotta obtain a resident weapon
from the throne which those are our
activities
yeah it'll it'll drop like blues
got it
is there anything else in here this is
crazy yeah i've got to look at around
for a sec
all these molds on the wall and stuff
so the collector's edition has a little
poster with the glam on it
which is like the hidden
analyzing it
and one of the
more interesting items that i hadn't
thought about was like
the
the analysis is talking about how big it
is and how like
whoever wielded it before must have been
pretty huge and i was like oh [ __ ]
original wielder
these uh these darkness statues over
here yeah come down here come down here
what is this
whoa what's going on down here
oh
oh these take damage
yeah some kind of like exotic or
something
directly into that hole oh yeah okay
oh it kind of looks like this part
these like casings and like moldings are
so sick
okay
should we go yeah yeah
that was
something
not sure exactly what that something was
or what that something did to you
hopefully nothing bad
yeah so all that stuff had to have been
pyramid tech right
it is yes absolutely yeah
here i was bemoaning the fact that we
now had two mysteries to solve
and you wilson making breakthroughs left
and right
so
the relic rendered a full blueprint out
of a single fragment
almost as if you were shaping that
weapon based on its own memory
which parallels the distortions all over
the planet
open wounds where the past bleeds into
the present
somehow the relic can manipulate time
with the right conduit of course
which savathun happened to have
but could she use the relic and what for
the questions just keep piling up it
seems the answers are buried within
savathun's throne
i need someone to go in and dig them up
guardian
how do you feel about working with the
hidden
oh [ __ ]
the hidden is like i chorus faction
right
i cora's secret spy group right right
wasn't eris like one of them like one of
her christmas one yeah harris was one uh
church is one
handful of other people nice
oh synaptic spear
this is season the river
oh so is this is this the uh this is our
artifact yeah we just got ours yeah okay
oh yeah carry the light with you
um
i'm gonna hold off on those champ mounts
until we know what we're dealing with
yeah let me
inspect the artifact though real quick
and just see
see the phone suppression
this time we're going to be
able to unlock everything
on the artifact eventually
oh really
yeah you won't have to pick you can get
all the mods
obviously it's going to take a while but
of course
you can do it yeah i'm very excited
about that oh dude yeah like everything
in this final one is like all based on
suppression
like yeah dude yeah suppressing gives
you better duration or it will siphon
energy to like your least charged
ability and
suppressing will weaken oh suppressive
darkness okay
let's avoid them up
let's slap them up
i'm gonna
i'm gonna run back down into that room
in the relic because as the chat noted
i did not pull out my ghost to see if he
had any insights
so i'm gonna try it real quick he
usually doesn't though ghost never knows
what the hell's going on
[Laughter]
he used to be a computer like ghost is
dumb as hell
he is he really is though like
he's like wow i have no idea what's
happening i was like yeah me neither
thanks bro i love him
no he's great but
uh yeah there's nothing in here
this is first that is now the time for
us to pop our
bounty's been saving up
yeah i think you can right yes so
because yeah we haven't even leveled
that
yeah so it's not like
you get the you know the first five
levels or whatever is
double xp
yeah something i was concerned about but
yes
even
yeah exactly
i i had a couple on this one though i
had a couple on this one but
you can actually see all the patterns
oh nice
oh okay in the catalog section huh nice
oh
oh very hot
we're opening a new lore book
fun
it's called
martian missive said the first one is
about osiris
i'll read this while you guys do
whatever you're doing oh i see the lore
book so we we unlock it as we do the the
legendary missions huh
yeah story in general there you go
okay
oh this is a message from osiris he's
not dead congratulations that's great
i wonder if he has brain damage
was a concern
oh
okay
so is this map that we're looking at is
this a map of mars or a map of the
throne world
let's see that's this is the throne okay
okay
so mars itself
isn't explorable it's only this uh
enclave that we have here yeah it's just
it's just this
like little spot right and then of
course the the first story mission which
is replayable right
uh yes it is
okay cool also i wonder if there's any
hidden spooky stuff out here let's go
take a look
oh there's here's a whole other area
the on cue
also check okay come down come down to
where i am yeah
this whole pocket of time is on fire
check that out see it down there yeah
did we totally wade through some of that
i don't do we but that's a mess
well i remember like as soon as we
spawned the first mission there was like
the weird like time pockets and stuff
but it wasn't fire it was like you know
drops and stuff
like that this one's on fire
when it's on fire
the piece of the pass that it's
remembering is the city being wrecked
oh i see what you're saying yeah yeah so
it's like it's like a look into a
different like time
uh you're seeing into it the past right
is on fire
yeah that is that is wild dude so that's
the aftermath to the left right here you
know what i mean all this like decay and
the sand like yeah that's sick but i'm
thinking we're looking at we're not just
looking at the past we might be looking
at the collapse in particular right
right which was that's [ __ ] up like
the like the collapse before the dark
age or whatever right
when the darkness showed up and
destroyed the world basically but what
if we're looking at the future
we're like the final shape of life while
there's some [ __ ] so what's there more
stuff over to the left and i wonder if
there's lore hidden out here too
i'm gonna have to go through all the
triumphs and figure it out yeah
there's you know i wouldn't be surprised
if there were little hidden things
oh we can't go out there okay what news
oh there's the crops okay i see it yeah
oh gotcha
oh sorry i read that osiris lore that
was pretty wild
yeah i didn't finish it
while you're doing that i'm gonna do
that
oh yeah pro tip make sure you're in a
fire team and in a destination when you
pop your bounties so you get bonus xp
okay
he got a shader
whoa what
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh man okay so that's interesting
um david the
lore is basically a message from osiris
apparently from before
season or
i guess
back in beyond light before he was
saboteun yeah
and it's he's like listen i've decided
to let sabothune take over my body
because i think the vanguard needs
to help or something like that and wild
yeah well okay so
um there's a lore entry from the
seasonal lost
toward the end there where he was like
he's talking about how he's trapped
inside his own body
and like nobody knows it's not him that
he made he made a deal with septum and
it was not what he expected of course
yeah so that's interesting he was uh
yeah that's absolutely what he thought
he was gonna get was it and though it
said he was like oh i'm gonna get to
like hang out in her throne world and
basically like learn all this knowledge
yeah learn get some stuff
and he said
did he actually get to do that or not
maybe not doesn't sound like it i mean
the other lore book entry i forget the
name of it made it really made it sound
like he was he was trapped in his own
body
watching like saint 14 and aikora
interact with him
without realizing that it was him or
that he that wasn't him brother and uh
and he was very upset about it
and it sounded torturous so
this is very cool
sorry for you guys
yeah i'm ready i'm ready
legendary campaign
let's keep going
oh yeah
aerys says throne worlds are kingdoms of
thought
built according to the desires of the
creator
i suppose sabathun desired a throne
world made of light
everything here is imbued with it
what's strange to me is that she's
vulnerable here
why would she just let us walk in
we need a clue about how she stole the
life
how do you guys swap from uh range to
melee
attack yes
okay
how do you do the shield
uh you hold down um right click
um
[Laughter]
great
it's got the cool like little like void
atoms like circling the
certainly
oh boy
we got a
super
oh
things are ruthless i can already
imagine them in the raid and how much of
a pain they're going to be
versus ghosts
why can't i pop this
we have to kill him twice or is it just
in a weird spot
oh that sucks
i'm gonna have to keybind that ghost
thing to like
something close by
yeah
i think the default is like eight or
something safe in a place
are you with the vanguard
hello
we lost him
i can trace the signal
any leads a good lead when you have no
leads that that wasn't glint was it like
you kind of had that oh boys actually
it was not glenn we got we got a we got
a newbie we have someone we haven't seen
before
oh
we're blocked but i'm picking up more of
that psychic energy over there
doing our way okay
deep
how did you do that
it's like you created those platforms
out of thin air
i don't know where i'm going do they go
the right way
i mean the the place kind of took us
this way right so i'm assuming yeah
oh yeah
spooky maze i saw this in the preview
too
kind of gotta like deep side our way
through here
i just picked a random direction
okay there's thralls down there and
there's another deep sight thing
well if you were like don't follow me
and i was just like on your tail
okay here we go
platforms this way
i think that door will lead us out
we just need a way up
[Music]
oh revenant knight with a
moth shield
all right here's another resonance
statue pointing
platforms
uh-oh
a little bit on the ground
up
sorry i'm just looking at stuff
don't follow me around i'm going to
check corners for like boards
i will definitely lead you off cliffs
like i did
hey you're stirring up the hive this
this is exactly why i told you to leave
what do you know about hive using the
light
that's why you're here
that's need to know
yeah yeah
all right i really shouldn't be doing
this but come meet me outside the
fortress just be discreet all right
i love this like evil dreaming city hall
thing going on
[Music]
poker up there
so
oh this way
look at these guys doing they're like
singing and swimming
what where
right here in this fountain
oh yeah
this one's got a flower grown out of its
head
yeah this whole place is
wild
i gotta mess with gear for a second yeah
i'm not gonna lie that's like a patrol
zone this place looks and feels
gigantic
but from a top down level when you look
at the map it doesn't seem that
crazy but like
i don't know the way they like
designed the space which is pretty huge
wanna go see if there's a gold chest
over here
uh sure
uh oh wrong way other one one of the
region chests
yeah
yeah absolutely it's on the map
i want to say it's right here by the
wall
okay should be through this door and to
the left
maybe
dick and zuno were if the chat were
contemplating the fact that i always
seem to pick fights with the big knights
with my glaive
with like the melees instead of the
smaller guys
so i'm always just trying to stab him
it should be right here
somewhere maybe it's up on the ramp oh
yeah yeah probably up on the
horse yeah behind it
yeah we're almost we're almost sorry on
top of it
oh there's a invis wall like
not letting me
yeah it's like a barrier
you jump on this thing here but then
yeah
definitely cannot
hey i found a little uh thing over here
which fine
um
maybe
that's a bloodborne shortcash
or it might be a deep sight resonance
thing that we're looking for
oh yeah
oh yeah here i hear weird oh yeah it's
immune yeah cool cool
um yeah okay so i imagine there are
secret platforms or something
that we have to access to get that chest
so it's around here somewhere
yeah i just wanted to like
keep it over there and take a look
yeah absolutely absolutely
blistered knight
and a moth guy
are gonna be all over you i happen to be
a discreet
we're trying to open the gate
just try to stay alive all right once
the gates open make a run for it
on fire
it's wild too's the glaze like my
highest uh
highest leveled stuff
yeah by far what did you do
oh you triggered the alarm the hive are
going to be all over you
happen to be in the street
make a run for it
um
kind of like that there's no radar on
legendary
it makes things like really intense
yo my boy buddy's like siphoning that it
was like slowing the knight down that
was cool
oh really
like health
yep
actually
i guess it could be a rogue hidden agent
or a lost guardian
but maybe it's just sabbath disguising
her voice yeah i'd be i'd be pretty
sucks
something puts like a dummy ghost for us
okay
sorry i just looking and stuff now
you're fighting your foot
corner
oh yeah here we go
the scorn
no
where are they
all right what are they doing
let's go
oh and our right and our right
oh
all right fair guard is
down unless if there's more
i can't tell if it was only one or three
i see him
nice
okay other side
okay
hmm
oh oh oh oh no careful careful there's
the the hive super
wizard now yeah
damn sorry
okay
yeah yeah you gotta have 25 seconds for
me
oh no
she pops
i can't get over there can you invisible
yeah
i'm just over here
let's
yeah right
let's get him in
on the left
how does it
feel here
that's messed up
all right
i need i need some ammo somewhere
i'm just going to put on some finder
mods real
all
quick
that's fire
or something
the uh other barrier guard is
calmed in on us
suppressed
all right this one's going down
another bubble
[Applause]
grenades i do
okay um
let's uh take her out real quick yeah we
got it we got it
i got it i got it i got it
that's
it a joke not sure i'll ever get used to
seeing ghosts serving the hive this is
like
this is a welcome difficulty though
just before i got a new i can turn
and they passed right over humanity and
chose our enemy instead
i can't forget that
i saw a bunch of stuff oh yeah i wasn't
yeah
[Music]
well okay so a thing in the collector's
edition i think this is what he was just
talking about and we were paying
attention um is that there are a number
of ghosts
that seem to be
um not only like supporters of the hive
and interested in the books of sorrow
which is the whole hive creation myth
but also just like feel bad for the hive
and think that they are
um like an underclass that have been
manipulated by the worms this whole time
and that they don't deserve to be
murdered constantly by us
i mean
makes sense
yeah yeah that checks out that they also
have committed a
massive genocide
they're super war criminals yes that's
true
but they also have to be because
otherwise they are murdered by their
ghosts or by their uh worms right right
so the other thing is
there's some speculation by the hidden
that these ghosts are not just
um
unable to they're they're unpaired
ghosts right they're not they haven't
found their guardians and the hidden are
speculating that some of them or maybe
all of them
aren't just unpaired because they
haven't been able to find a guardian but
are unpaired because they've chosen not
to find a guardian right contentious
objective conscientious objectors
exactly so there's you know a lot of
speculation and worry
out of that that like maybe these ghosts
that were working for the hive aren't
there was there was a bit a while ago
where sabathune was like or osiris as
sabbath
was investigating dead ghosts and stuff
like that interested in all that garbage
and
so
you know we were wondering oh did she
just resurrect a bunch of ghosts and
turn them into hive ghosts
or are they our ghosts
who hang out in the city and don't like
us
and have decided to become hive ghosts
right which is a big deal like there's
this is very interesting like we're just
crushing these ghosts left and right
but these ghosts
are not
all that different from our ghost right
they are still people the same way
regular ghosts are people
right so
i don't know it's uh it's interesting
anyway here's the scoring totem thing
oh yeah we're getting into this part
david
uh
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah there's yes pyramid
so you said the legendary difficulty
scales right so like yes so you could
try three of them right but you could
try this like solo and it'll still be
tough i'd imagine but it's like maybe
instead of three freaking
hive guardians or whatever broods like
the big dudes there's only one yeah it
makes sense
um yeah and bungie made it sound like
you should be able to
if you're skilled if you if you're a vet
you should probably be able to solo it
day one gotcha it won't be impossible
it's not like soloing a gm nightfall
it's somewhere
less than that i guess right yeah so
yeah it's tough definitely but
we're in the swamp part oh i'm gonna my
it sounds like my wife is on a call yeah
yeah i can hear you know
you might want to mute that
you you brought us here
ask her what she thinks about the
darkness
just
let me explain
the big twist
we've been talking to a hive ghost
okay
uh
hello games uh yes if you were to buy
this game and you were to buy this
expansion um it would automatically
start you at the level in which you
could play the expansion so if that's
what you're interested in you could
totally do that
i think even the free-to-play
conscience
objector literally says that yeah okay
that's so cool
hey you know get awkward out of the way
first i always say
this uh pile of ash and bone
used to be my uh
actually
don't worry about it
all you need to know us wandering ghosts
gave into the hive believing wheat
found purpose and well
peer pressure is a hell of a thing
also because it's what the traveler must
have wanted yeah then hive killed
guardians with light and you think
that's the traveler's will really
i'll tell you what i don't buy it not
anymore the witch queen's up to
something and you know maybe together we
get to the bottom of it huh
there's an old hive temple nearby with
savithine secrets inside that is all i
know the one in the y that's your game
yeah
and when you get there radio me private
channels only
almost forgot
the name's finch
honor to meet you yeah
for real real
sweet
okay we got a full quest from this
oh
all right
sick
is all these i like all these question
marks makes me want to know
what they are it's confidential quests
also guys i see in the chat people are
out like thinking you need to like grind
to level up like oh not at all dlc no
you don't know not at all everyone it
will start you it will start you at the
same level that we started at yes
everyone everyone starts at 13 50.
it doesn't matter if you just picked it
up day one or if you've been playing for
the last like four years or whatever
everyone starts at 13 50.
bounties
yeah we got to get a quest i was going
to be i was like oh [ __ ] did you do you
have access to it like how
okay and now they're giving us the
option they're like hey if you want you
can go start the uh
yeah this season
[Music]
should we keep going on the legendary
i don't know do you guys do you guys
want to do a little bit of the
um i i'm down i'm down to do some
seasonal stuff yeah
that's up to you
oh hey what's this
oh what is this come over here you guys
they're like bounties
like actual bounties
reports of uniquely moth in the
apothecary reports of a unique-looking
mountain quagmire
can i pick them up i'm trying to mash
your hands i was gonna say i can't do
anything yeah maybe not yet
fascinating
that's cool
all right well
uh you want to go back to the enclave
then is that where we have to be
no we have the meeting in the helm no in
the hangar
let's go to the helm let's go now the
hanger in the tower
no the hangar
[Music]
i see it oh also there's um
get the catalyst for yeah i'm gonna take
the opportunity to run around the tower
yeah let's go do that
uh also
how much longer do you want to go
streaming david uh it's up to you
i'm done for whatever
i've got to keep going as much or as
little as possible we can go to like
maybe let's say like the end of the hour
until like
1. if that's if that's okay
yeah that sounds good sweet
yeah i might i might uh do the uh the
legendary and try to like solo some of
it just to like take my time and
kind of enjoy the the environment but
i'm down to like play through and see as
much as the season of the risen
hey phil so in the triumphs it says like
which being chapter one and like each
uh
like step would get would get like a
lore page
is that chapter one considered like one
full mission or is it four missions
i don't know and that's right okay
or is that chapter one just referring to
like the lord book or something
um it appears to me that
they've divided the missions up in two
sections so that's like yeah four
missions equals the first chapter
we just we've seen the first chapter of
the witch queen story in the next scene
oh actually it's gonna be much
that was four missions and chapter two
was like eight
looks like so
oh you can buy an ascendant alloy from
ravel
400 legendary shirts though
and i'm
super low on legendary shirts
checking now
will buy your stuff too oh and he'll buy
etheric yes he's the he's the new spider
right yeah okay
and if your spiral can go for color so
at least today very nice
let's get started
yeah sending alloy is a crafting thing
are we going to figure out all those
currencies
[Music]
oh dude the glaive on on your back is
just this giant
[Laughter]
oh that is awesome
i'm just running around
you're like
[Laughter]
just bumping them
[Laughter]
take some poor guy's head off like just
turning too fast like
oh you can res it's okay where's your
ghost
uh sir that was just a uh a regular man
from the last city
oh whatever i'm the the guardian
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
v with the capital t like
holy [ __ ] i love that
oh okay uh
oh we have to go talk to i see yeah you
guys set the hanger huh okay
yeah
let's do it let's do it
you know that was not the whole campaign
absolutely not that was definitely just
like
that was that was like that was like
step one out of a bunch more we're just
trying to show off a bit of the seasonal
stuff which is happening kind of like
adjacent to the campaign
and in fact the game even kind of
occurred
like if you want you can go like start
this stuff
you're kind of meant to maybe do a
little bit of it uh
you know simultaneously yeah
oh yeah they strip like a cabal ship
here
no way
all right i'm on my way let me talk to
the hawthorne real quick
if you buy the normal version of the dlc
do you need about the season pass
separately uh yes right yes
season passes like 10 bucks right
yeah uh if you get the deluxe version
it's included
of the
if you're just more like oh i just want
to try this expansion i'm not sure if
i'm going to keep playing destiny after
like maybe wait you know don't waste the
donations the money right i think it's
also cheaper to get it all at one go
it is cheaper get on when you go you
know sort of like uh hey if you're not
actually gonna end up liking it i don't
know right that's probably get you
that's how they get you right they're
like well you know if you do like it
you'll save some money but you're just
like it's like five dollars it's not
that much money i don't know
but
i've i did that with like halo 4 back in
the day where i bought like the season
pass because i'm like i love halo i'm
going to play it's cheaper and i'll get
all these maps
like that multiplayer at all and i was
like well all right
i'm never doing that again i will say
that uh
the seasons the last year have been
super
when you're ready sean like i can make
this thing oh sure yeah
yeah yeah one sec one sec though real
quick someone was just wanting to
quickly look at the season pass while we
were talking about it so i'm just going
to show them oh sure sure the track bar
you can show it off yeah you basically
got so i mean yeah you have the free
track on top
and i think you don't need the season
pass to get the the top bar right
you can just access that yeah yeah
that's the free pass right so but if you
pay for the season pass you get the
exotic right off the bat and then you
get extra goodies shaders
uh a fun little finisher that uses a
mock
if uh the game wants to load it
oh yeah here it is
it looks sick
it's like you like blow them off at
someone like a little kiss and they just
explode
so sick
yeah you get a bunch of sparrows and all
that
there's also like xp bonuses the more
that you uh
unlock is some of the rewards which is
cool
but yeah and obviously like the
selling point is the activities and
stuff there's exactly exactly there's
more story there's uh you know special
things that you can do and someone asked
about difficulty you choose the
difficulty in the throne world so if you
go to the throne world assuming you have
the dlc you can pick the regular
campaign the classic version or you can
pick the legendary one which scales
yeah mission by mission you can change
it so like you can do one legendary if
it's too hard or you know like you have
to
play alone after you're playing with the
team it'll scale down right based on
like dynamically as you're playing but
also if you want to
click down to a lower difficulty you can
at any time yeah and play it and then
you can come back and do each of the
missions
um on legendary like in your own time or
at your own pace or whatever and there's
a bigger there's a big reward for doing
it all
i'm legendary you get the 50 the 15
20 arm or whatever it is right which
basically raid ready and you get exotics
and stuff but you don't you know
obviously you don't have to and you can
do it
one at a time or whenever you feel like
yeah it's like a halo campaign it's
basically exactly like the halo
difficulty in the halo games where you
can do heroic for a bit then you can do
legends and then you can go back
whatever i forget the difficulties but
exactly
and i'm good to go i have phil's
favorite emote
right now
i hate that
[Laughter]
what are the lower implications of the
cat ear dance phil do you want to
[Music]
bet that i bet it's
i bet there's some cannon [ __ ]
[Laughter]
they're too good about that
they're too good about that
i'll talk about a funny lord thing in a
minute
oh yeah sounds like a cutscene okay you
opened fire on us my warriors were
responding to unexpected threats i'm
surprised
yes we did you're sure i'd go in there
if i were you
crow is so cool the rules of engagement
had changed
i don't need to listen to this
guardian
what for to discourage
indeed
i'm fresh from performing cabal funeral
rites
care to explain
our condolences empress
your people fought and died with honor
but they didn't have to
we can all prevent future losses if we
choose to put the incident on mars
behind us and work together
what we discovered there is a threat to
both humanity and the cabal
you want my help
want is a strong word
you need my
help i don't know how the hive came into
possession of the light
my core will find out
but in the meantime
invincibility lies in the defense
the possibility of victory in the attack
sun tzu
i've read your texts
[Music]
you want us to hit them
i need us to hit them
hard
um responding to chat is the dungeon in
this new season neo 42 well asked and no
it is not it's coming
i think there are two actually right and
they're right sometime in the future
yeah um we haven't we don't have the
details on that yeah
new colors for the uh they are included
in the deluxe edition of uh witch queen
though which implies that you're gonna
have to pay for them separately
rapiers
whoa
yeah that that
weird spear
yeah this helm is pretty cool that it's
like a living space you know um
[Music]
i meet you in blood guardian
there was violence between your people
and mine
this will be forgiven
once
our alliance must be strong to stand
against savathun's hive
i see commander icora has delivered the
synaptic spear
light-suppressing cabal technology
refined and weaponized
locate a hive lieutenant
one brimming with savathun's influence
my scions will force it into their
mindscape and connect your light to the
light of the weakened hive
it will struggle against you
you will face embodiments of its belief
in sovereign
take up your spear and destroy them and
it will be left lightless without the
light or a worm
the hive will die
unless my scions keep it alive
we will bring it to your helm
and sift through its broken mind to
discover its secrets
all under the watchful eye of your lord
saladin
i have led many warriors into battle
but this psychic warfare
i will enjoy the experience
fight well guardian
bring glory to both our clans and break
these hive against the bow of our union
all right
uh answering more questions new strikes
i think there are two
new ones they are new ones they're not
returning mars strikes
mars is back but none of the bars
contest
is
the reinforcements we sent were lost
we are facing a new enemy this sounds
like more war crimes
i will not allow it so i'm
but before it can die
we capture it bring it here
for psychic analysis
tidal scions are the key to this
operation
if you see them on the battlefield
resist the urge to open fire
we need them to learn what happened to
our guardians and how to stop it from
ever happening again
the hive are at our doorstep
they think their corrupted light gives
them the strength to stand against us
now go to the edz and show them how
wrong they are
damn selling and still grumpy as ever
and he wants us to like not kill the
scions basically
no we the scions are our buddies okay
okay
yeah yeah and he's he's all about like
dude the hive ghost or this is like
sacrilegious like
it's awful
i see bounties i click on them
not enough space
oh i'm at max quest capacity
i was going crazy
i could probably delete some of the
the old pass stuff
okay you could uh
you you do your umbrella focusing over
here now
yeah
rahul can do it too
yeah oh nice
that's honestly better like less
multiple menus you have to run around
into
vastly prepare that
all right should we go murder some hive
in the edzy
uh yeah let's do it
let's do it
oh don't forget to use your your deep
sight resonance guns in order to unlock
yeah yeah definitely i think that's all
i'm going to be wanting to use to be
honest because they look really cool in
the menu with like the
the extra red bar and like the
okay you guys ready yeah i'm ready
all right
psyops battleground
very early still but i mean as someone
who likes destiny um i think it's pretty
freaking awesome so far there is a huge
amount of new stuff so if you're into
this game yeah it's probably a good idea
yo this is a great pve perk stats for
all hitting three separate targets
increases weapon handling stability
reload and range for a moderate duration
oh that's interesting so if you're just
ad clearing
like
what like that i would want that
goofy like take on one for all a new one
that's fun yeah
and i got it combined with wellspring so
i'm just getting abilities
in this region
oh he's got the
the coordination of the attacks
indicates a larger strategy
i know what it is
defeat one of them's lieutenants and
secure them for analysis
hey doesn't it feel great uh like
one-shotting
[Laughter]
oh whoa dude
edc is being corrupted what this is cool
oh yeah
that's a brilliant way to
kind of like keep a change of pace with
the older areas you know what i mean
like oh yeah we're going to make you go
to the edc but it's not going to be the
same so it feels like
a new environment
yeah exactly exactly that's very
embarrassing
we got a heavy box here
nice
got a knife
i think it's 100 what are we looking for
we're just looking for like
oh gosh i got that
now that we're not fighting
right
we found your missing warriors drained
of their light
and the hunting party responsible they'd
hoped to ambush a less formidable fire
team but they got us instead
find their leader and make them pay
guardian
oh we're going into the um
yeah
a quick thing that neo brought up in
chat was mentioning that the season pass
alone would probably not be worth it but
when you buy this season you're not just
buying the season pass the season pass
is like an extra perk right because
you're really
paying for like the
other elements that the seasonal
activities and stuff would bring you
right
yeah
yeah it's not just i mean you get like
it's more gear it's exotic
yeah yeah so there are there are exotic
quests and stuff tied with
you must do the same
seize their blades
it's definitely
[Applause]
yeah we got this guy here
there we go
that's cool combining high things and
guardian things
[Laughter]
dude this is awesome because like this
place doesn't even look remotely
recognizable
you know what i mean despite being where
the the chart was i think and so
yeah
yeah
a little bit
right
yeah like
exactly
so that that's cool that's really smart
it's probably the one thing i respect
the most about destiny is like the
delicate balancing act they're always
doing in terms of like
okay
okay
i think i got it though i got the
triumph
uh
let me see where the
another over here
oh there you go
[Music]
[Applause]
oh there it is
it's a mental projection built by my
scions what sever the witch queen's
connection to this hive before it
escapes
it's like what uh
okay this was cool
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
oh nice level
oh is it like a really noticeable faster
cast is so much
oh that's cool very noisy
i thought about a star horse for a wild
second i'm not gonna lie
those second projections
[Laughter]
oh my god
oh really in the air
yeah
this is insane
so what do you do with the spear do you
just like throw it at him
gotcha
oh you've used it like multiple times
guys
[Music]
oh [ __ ] man
oh
that okay that is awesome
yeah yeah we captured so that whole
thing in their mind was like basically
controlling the
dude
when a warrior is slain in battle that
we called it
oh sorry
sorry okay
it ended for me i didn't realize it yeah
it's different dialogue
all right saladin was talking for a long
time about sifa and being sad oh wow
i forgot that the dialogue will be
different
i got a
so i got an armor piece that
has like an intrinsic perk
uniformed officer yeah grants additional
cyogenic intel when completing
activities looks like it's like tidal's
armor oh that's the new stuff nice nice
nice so if you wear it i guess it like
just gives you a boon when you're doing
uh
when you're trying to like gather
materials i guess like the seasonal
material maybe
yeah that's cool because there hasn't
been a good reason to
uh use the seasonal stuff yeah so that's
that's nice i like that i like how just
everything is becoming more synergistic
and like
more perks involved
you know all these guns now have
actually encouraging use down there yeah
swap stuff out one like to use like
cirrus guns now have soros perks and
yeah
yeah like all that is all that is really
cool yeah a lot of that reminds me of
like
borderlands and the way they'd have like
oh like jacob's guns like babe this way
and like try to make that more
thing it's cool like it's all
more reasons to think about your loadout
which is something that the game has
been doing better lately but is still
not you know it hasn't been great about
that necessarily oh i got some dialogues
you're already getting results from the
mind scans of the hive you brought back
these things are ravenous
they're hungry for our power they're
hunting guardians draining their light
collecting it
we haven't discovered why
savathu knows how to keep a secret
and so do her hive
i need you to hunt more of them
cut them off from their light and make
them wither the face of ours
they hate us guardian
they want to use serpus
become us
i will never let that happen
god saladin is such a boomer
oh what
that's cool so
the
next part of like the quest is like
gather intel which you can do in the
throne world
nice nicely it's like a campaign mission
so i think you kind of want to keep
going like back and forth between right
maybe
oh yeah
you can go do strikes and gambit
whatever else
and it counts also
is there a new strike
um there are new strikes i'm pretty sure
but i don't know what they are i don't
think we've accessed them yet we
probably unlock them through the
campaign like how they've done
previously oh yeah there's a radio
message too
oh i like that dismantling stuff is just
giving gunsmith rank that's that's nice
[Music]
oh man
[Music]
oh yeah if you actually click on the
season thing it tells you uh it's a nice
little like road map
for uh neo if you're selling the chat
you can see what you have free so the
void subclass updates weapon crafting
and guardian games coming later probably
like in the summer i guess
is uh free for everyone and then
past specific stuff is the psyops
battlegrounds
universal or armor ornaments for
cosmetics and then the exotic quest
that's only for you have to buy the
season pass for that stuff
[Music]
nice
all right we got about 15 minutes we
want to run anything in that
uh whatever you want time that we think
could be cool
i mean i want to get back in there
in the throne roll
yeah
why don't we do some uh why don't we do
like some lost sectors or something
that's run world like run around yeah
let's go do let's do yeah yeah yeah
that's good that would be that'd be cool
[Music]
yeah okay
um
hold on just one sec
i'm really curious to see these lost
sectors because lost sectors despite
like early in destiny 2 being kind of
like oh there's not like good loot or
whatever but the locations are some of
the coolest you know they're really
they're a great idea yeah that's what i
like to know and they're really like
well designed and i just love the
environments like it's these places that
you're constantly running past all the
time and if you just like go in there's
like these areas you've never you know
you wouldn't imagine are there right
like they go really deep sometimes
they also have like little
interesting stories almost all of them
like the tangled shore one that's a
dance club for the fallen oh yeah yeah
which which ripped to that you know
yeah
um here we're gonna i'm gonna mark a
public event and do that and then right
next to it is a loss sector oh perfect
we might
wonder if it's new
the new one publix because yeah we gotta
figure out how to make them heroic
yeah
oh yeah then we're gonna have to put up
with a bunch of new people not making
them hurry
so it says the reward you get is rare
gear but also you get thrown world rank
okay nice
and that and that's with the uh yeah
finch okay cool let's grab this while
we're here yeah
a trophy can signal it's garbled
the hive must be jamming us finch
oh
uh wait so amaro who's torturing young
ghosts
oh
pick up yeah
immediately
but at who's behest we do not yet know
we'll keep starving them until we figure
out who's behind all this
thanks aikora
yes this way
oh no
oh well
that's fine we'll keep going
oh no it's here
oh here it is okay cool either original
okay
um
these
here we go
oh
yeah the season was kind of i don't know
okay
i don't know
yeah
it's a little sluggish it doesn't you
know
immediately destroy everyone
it reminds me a lot of xenophage in the
beginning what xenophage was like
everyone was like this is ass why are we
used to this
and then it became incredible
yeah man
is it the one that that like fires like
super [ __ ] fast because i've been
using that one too and there's a lot of
fun
yeah
i got it
oh no i'm on fire again
dude i cannot get over the warlocks new
melee i love that
the animation is so sick
okay there we go
[Music]
i'm so curious dude this whole place is
sick look at this swamp man like what
okay hold on i want to check my gun real
quick it's also yeah and i'm just gonna
gush about this place for a second
because like it's it's still the throne
world right but it looks wildly
different from the like elegant dark
souls cathedral type [ __ ] that we were
seeing
just like what 10 minutes ago you know
like
that is amazing it's like a
it's worth story-wise whole thing is
supposed to reflect the inside of
septum's mind right right this is the
old
portion her old hive history
right right right with the darkness and
so on and like
where we were the the bright clean city
areas that you like
it's like a re-imagination right like
yeah
oh the light portion yeah okay come here
come here come here to me
where are you oh okay i see i was
following this blueberry i thought it
was you for a second mr uh mr big gold
i don't know what this is but i'm
touching it
oh collect fundamental osmium
oh you know it's maybe it's the
materials
[Music]
the septuagint oryx and
rap
were all
princesses
um on this world called fundament
and their dad was the osmium king so
they were the osmium court
basically the dynasty of
the hive as you know it is the osmium
court i guess
so
yeah um
but you know they were deposed and then
they found the worms and then they
became even
yeah
uh
no where is it it's right here it is
right here
the phil's gotta
that's not okay
it's like phil's gotta
[Laughter]
oh sick all right
dude nothing hits like a day one
experience of all this i'm sensing light
there we go but we haven't encountered
any sources of light elsewhere
any inside finch just
light
you sure because my scans
they're showing score
oh they are question marks for me dude
i can't even i can't even hit him yeah
[Music]
do we have to be what am i at right now
13.88 i guess yeah let's say last
sectors are generally pretty high
well that's funny what light are you
guys at right now
uh or power level 13.94
uh
i'm like 89. okay okay yeah yeah so yeah
that's that's a no-go
damn all right
just running with our
tail uh
between our legs
well that's fine i think we can call it
here um
yeah oh yeah that's true and then we did
the we did a public event we had some
new stuff
gotta check out a swimming pool another
let's kill this high value
all right
yeah i got one more super reckoning
like i'm already here but wait is this a
little assassination
oh get the [ __ ] out of here dog
[Applause]
voice things on their uh instagram and
facebook
oh really three days yeah they're
teasing this hive guardian or hive
i'd go yeah but amaro isn't uh i mean he
didn't drop the daddy line on those
posts i don't
think yikes
he said he said some weird [ __ ] whoa
where are we call this glitter bombs or
something like that yeah i don't know
we're just underground someplace oh this
is nuts dude look at this uh i think the
steep side right here
oh it's portal oh [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
where'd you go
i don't know i'm upset and worried
there's scoring guys here so these guys
have skulls
uh okay well
i guess the glaze just took them out
maybe they hurt us
yeah our objective's telling us to kill
these guys real quick
okay okay
there's deep sight
oh yeah
go yeah let's uh
i'd never want to hear
daddy and maru talk again
sorry nope
that's what you get for using that emo
yeah
that's what i get yeah oh that's my
punishment i see okay i got you thank
you
with me real quick let's see what's over
here okay
i'll see the portal and then i'll wrap
up the uh
whoa
yeah this is creepy right what the [ __ ]
are we on the map yeah where are we oh
yeah it doesn't even show
oh [ __ ] okay
yeah we i don't i don't see someone now
this is sick man
like super super dreadnought energy too
which is the best stuff it's so into the
game yeah yeah this game rules when
reddit doesn't [ __ ] spoil everything
uh
yeah
i like it
that's the one thing that when people
talk about old destiny like one
nostalgia i do agree with is people are
like i liked when destiny just
didn't didn't tell you anything yeah you
just kind of figured it out and it was
like i do think there was like a little
bit lost when it's like well now that
it's like you have eight seasons you
kind of have to like
tell people
yeah to like court them in
[Music]
yeah i feel it
well all right that was that was a good
uh that was a good taster so chad i hope
you guys enjoyed uh the time there were
some you know audio issues but overall
we ran around got to see
yeah we got to see mars got to see some
cool cutscenes even some seasonal stuff
so
definitely uh stay tuned and oh also
check out uh the video that john luke
and i have made it's on our channel you
can check it out it's called so you've
decided to play destiny 2. we put in a
lot of work a lot of heart into it and
it's a lot of fun it's a very funny
video you can share it to your friends
check it out if you've been curious
about the game if you're a new player if
you're just trying to uh you know court
other folks to join your fire team i
think it's a great video to share uh and
also just stay tuned to us because check
out gamespot.com phil's gonna be going
off the chains with guides and uh you
know the incoming review and stuff in a
couple weeks and we're gonna have a lot
of cool stuff for you we will have a lot
of coverage we're gonna talk about story
we're gonna talk about all the new
mechanics we're gonna have guides for
all that stuff we're gonna
uh we're gonna go deep we're gonna have
it all so yeah absolutely and hit us if
you guys have questions or whatever hit
us up in the comments oh man this sniper
just annihilated me
look at our just like doing our little
farewell dance you're getting toasted i
am i'm in a hole
awesome well then in that case stay safe
all and enjoy the rest of your tuesday
later bye